hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Johnny Bentham is considered a father
militarism because he's the one who
gives a name and brings it together and
consolidates it in a systematic way yeah
Bevin himself
his primary interest was in forming the
British legal system because they had a
lot of you know obviously obviously the
punishment should fit the crime there
were a lot of punishments that did not
fit the crime they were very arbitrarily
applied or they were too severe they
didn't pay off in good consequences yeah
that's when he taught Arianism is moral
theory he am like all moral theories it
has support effects it has to tell us
what the good is what the bad is how we
should make our decisions how we should
evaluate you know choices policies
institutions things like that it has to
give us some sort of guidance or
principles for reaction for deciding
what we ought to do so utilitarianism is
starting from a evenness basis we've
talked about that before what's even as
says it pleasure pleasure is good and
therefore pain is that and we have to
talk about this as a form of
consequentialism meaning that it looks
at ultimately what sort of consequences
are produced so if if it's more pleasure
than pain overall that's good if it's
more pain and pleasure overall that's
produced then that's bad so for example
take something very very silly hitting
yourself in the head of the hand all
right maybe not even get into that right
nope because if you do then you need to
talk to someone because that there's
that's not gonna pay off very well you
get yourself in that in a hammer it's
going to hurt right you've all done
something stupid like that at one point
in Thor or another with something stuck
you're taking a light socket or you
touched a mousetrap or you lick the cold
pole you know and so they told you to
your thumb with a hammer doing things
now how do you know that that's a bad
thing
well because it produces a lot of pain
some people like to do things like that
because get some sympathy afterwards now
for most people is that going to be a
good procedure no because the sympathy
is not going to be so pleasurable than
the along with the pain of actually the
head of the hammer which is going to
hurt for a while you know if you do it
right if you actually were able to
produce more pleasure than pain by doing
that then from a hedonist perspective it
would be a good thing it doesn't work
that way in real life you know that's
why we don't get ourselves
what if you expanded the field of people
who are effective you're not just
interested in yourself
utilitarianism in the entire community
people factor what if I did the class
huh
and I would come in and I would get
myself to the end of the hammer and it
would hurt my help but all of you would
get a real big kick out look at that
dumb professor doing that sort of thing
and it really made your day would it be
worth it that's an interesting question
from a bent from a bathtub you know
utilitarian perspective if your pleasure
the pleasure generated by that
outweighed the amount of pain that I
feel that it would be a good thing to do
so that's sort of a basic fun day out
SketchUp of what utilitarianism is about
as a moral theory it's the moral theory
that is saying what we want to do is
maximize pleasure I'm good I'm trying to
minimize pain as much as possible for
all of the people affected in my
research Bentham calls this idea is
principle
principle of utility that's where we
gave the word utilitarianism from other
people were using this word ability
before he was on the scene and then
that's you know a tendency to produce
happiness or pleasure or a greater
balance of pleasure over pain if
something is useful for you for example
you know why are those shoes that you're
wearing useful for you they're kind of
fashionable you know they've got some
interesting design features to them but
what's that that's the most important
thing you think about the shoes culprit
yeah do they actually fit me and then
what else will be the second-most
besides it looks yeah well we said
comfort
well comfort Alaska you know will you've
got them in the store that way I'm going
to laugh exactly
durability is the pleasure is that is
the benefit to me going to continue over
time so there's the question of benefit
in the first place comfort comfort as a
lack of pain more than more than
pleasure and then how long is it going
to go on for and then you know then
there's the aesthetics I'm assuming that
you block those and so the green ones
are purple ones that look the same thing
is you actually like that it produces
greater pleasure for you to look at
right principle of utility is saying
that's the sort of thing that we want to
pay attention to when we're making moral
decisions what we ought to do is try to
maximize pleasure minimize pain and not
just for ourselves but for all persons
effectively and something that goes
along with this is that everybody's
pleasure or pain should count for as
much as everybody else's so it shouldn't
matter whether
I'm friends with somebody what I'm
deciding about who I want to benefit of
who I want to to harm and how I want to
balance these things out and I should
make myself count for more this is a
very common tendency right make
ourselves come for more than other
people so buy it with a little bit of
discomfort on my part can make another
person completely happy I should do that
that's what the principle of utility
would say I want to do okay so that's
the the basic idea
everybody's got that down right that's
that's clear enough utility is the
tendency to lead to pleasure what you
lead to a removal or prevention